I think of myself as a man of
contradictions I mean I first I am very
brutal in my way of thinking I love all
I hate it's black oh it's white which is
not very true because then a part of me
loves the gray festivals but anyway I
realized that I am a man of
contradiction and extreme and very often
I state something and within the same
sentence I contradict myself or I give a
rule and of course I add the exceptions
to that rule the discipline that I
demand in many of my arts the discipline
of spending hours in front of the mirror
perfecting a magic trick by manipulation
also comes with its antidote or its
extreme which is the opposite of
discipline
forget about what you're doing don't
work play and very often in my arts
taking the magic again as an example if
I stop working on a move but if I just
fool around as you would say with a deck
of cards you know watching a film or
talking to France suddenly out of the
playfulness will come a great invention
it could be a very small detail by the
way to turn a card or something that I
can use in a magic trick and it didn't
come from the discipline of work it came
from its opposite it came with playing
you know so I advocate that and I think
I am a a man who works very hard and
also plays very hard enjoy his life
you